[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROSE LIU: Hi, I'm Rose, a
software engineer working
on Google's Cloud
Spanner database.
HEATHER CROSS: And hello,
again, from me, Heather.
And thanks for joining us, Rose.
ROSE LIU: Glad to be here.
HEATHER CROSS: So
let's talk databases.
If you were developing
a new application,
what would you say is more
important, data consistency
or scalability?
ROSE LIU: Well, normally, we'd
have to choose between the two.
But in today's episode,
we'll talk about Google Cloud
Spanner, the first
relational database
service that provides
both strong transactional
consistency and horizontal
scalability to thousands
of nodes.
HEATHER CROSS: And towards
the end of this episode,
we'll also explore the
application of Cloud Spanner
within a self-based lab.
Let's get to it.
ROSE LIU: Cloud Spanner is
unique in the marketplace
because it combines
both relational database
structure with horizontal
scale and performance.
What this means is
that this significantly
simplifies application
development and database
management, allowing you to
deliver your apps faster.
For example, for globally
distributed apps,
Cloud Spanner's
multi-regional configuration
automatically replicates a
database across continents,
allowing for localized
reads, minimizing latency.
Creating or scaling such a
globally-replicated database
only takes a handful of clicks.
HEATHER CROSS: At Google,
we use Cloud Spanner
for our own mission
critical services
and apps that billions of
people access everyday.
So downtime just
isn't an option.
It's great that we can share
this battle-tested database
service with our Google
Cloud Platform users.
ROSE LIU: Cloud
Spanner databases
have an industry-leading
five nines
of availability SLA,
no plan downtime,
and enterprise-grade security.
HEATHER CROSS: If you have a
traditional relational database
system that's
bursting at the seams
or are struggling with
hand-rolled transactions
on top of an eventually
consistent database,
Cloud Spanner could be the
solution you're looking for.
ROSE LIU: Now it's
time for Qwiklabs.
In this lab, we'll show
you how to use the GCP
Console to create a Cloud
Spanner instance, database,
and table.
We'll also show you
how to add a schema,
write data, modify
it, and run a query.
HEATHER CROSS: You
can check out the link
to start the Qwiklab here.
Keep in mind that I'll take
about 30 minutes to complete.
At this point in the
lab, we've created
a Spanner instance, created
a database for the Spanner
instance, created a schema
for the database, inserted
some data into
the Singers table.
Now we're adding one more
item to the Singers table.
Next, we will select the item
and click Edit, make changes
to the item and click Save.
To delete the item, we will
select it, click Delete,
and click OK to confirm.
To query the table, we click
Query, update the query,
and click Run Query.
In this case, we get two
Singers that exist in our table.
ROSE LIU: Well, that's
the end of the episode,
and we really hoped
you enjoyed it.
We'd love to hear your feedback
and how you apply our services.
So please, do share.
HEATHER CROSS:
And don't forget--
GCP offers a 12-month free
trial with $300 in credits
so you can apply what
you've learned today
and start using
it with your data.
ROSE LIU: If you want to learn
more about Cloud Spanner,
check out our
training links below.
Thanks for watching.
And see you soon.